[Music]
so is there a video for this or it was
just a interview in a magazine interview
in a magazine right okay so what was the
exact quote let's read this that was
pretty english of you right there right
okay what was the exact quote is this
from like a publication or some kind of
editorial right okay magazine it's just
a few drops but yes me and machine gun
kelly do consume each other's blood on
occasion for ritual purposes only as
opposed to what exactly breakfast casual
yeah think about different that would be
if she said yeah we'd drink each other's
piss strictly for ritual purposes you
can make a ritual out of that for sure
there was a uh the other quote was about
her like manifesting him did you see
that no she was basically like i
manifested you i've been dreaming of you
since i was four and if it if it weren't
for me who knows what you would have
turned out like because i'm the reason
why you turned out like this okay
someone was like she's a classic
narcissist okay okay so the quote is i
lied there is the video yes
there's some [ __ ] up between megan fox
and this like manifesting thing and then
giselle tom brady's wife she apparently
like practices witchcraft or something
and she like apparently can predict if
he's going to do well in games and stuff
there's something just really funny to
me about when really uh attractive
powerful people they're like oh no i'm
i literally have super power
i'm not only famous
and hot i'm also a super
hero yeah and i just i always look at
this and i'm like are you sure that
works because like i think ugly people
manifest every day and they're stuck
doing
things they don't want to do some of
them are single some of them are not
successful they manifest all the time
looking in the mirror you know every day
when i make eye contact with my towel
rack as a 5 8 human i manifest i'm like
one day i'm gonna look in this mirror
and like it's gonna be
it's gonna be a good day yeah and that
is yet to happen so i just think it's
funny when just yeah really attractive
rich people are like no dude
i can control the universe i know that
sounds crazy but like i can
i can feel planets you're just not like
enlightened enough yeah you haven't
spent enough time working on you when i
lose sleep
um i can really feel the effect that
that has on my mental health and
traveling for work and being on
different time zones and how that
affects my pineal gland
perennial grant gland pineal gland the
one that's like in the middle of your
brain that like she's a scientist now
too
holy hell i never do recreational drugs
i'm always completely sober i don't even
drink a glass of wine i'm not saying you
have to be like that i'm saying for me
that that's how i feel the best
but also self-care is
enough quiet time to be able to connect
to my
super conscious my higher conscious to
connect to god to connect to spirit and
this lifestyle makes that very difficult
sometimes and i do feel very lost when
i'm not able you know what's wild is
it's a super conscience she's like
talking about like like eastern eastern
like spiritual ideas of like you have
like your physical body and then like
your like metaphysical bodies like uh
what's the term for it um like a plane
of existence how do i i know this [ __ ]
very well and then like some people
teach like there's like a causal body
that's like
beyond like material and matter it
exists like in thought and then like
your peak consciousness that's like
achieving like a highest form of
consciousness where like transcends like
physical being it's like the the
the image for it is like a thousand
petal lotus like that's like it's like
the top of your crown that's like your
highest chakra or whatever okay is that
related to the penal gland or the pineal
gland
yeah dude yeah i think the yeah the
pineal gland is like it like distributes
something like when you die it i think
it like distributes a bunch of like
chemicals in the same way as dmt and
like unlocks things
like there are like arguments that the
pineal gland is how that's how you get
to higher consciousness and stuff which
is like yeah that's true if if there's
literally like
700 milligrams of dmt just baked into
your brain if you crack that open yeah
of course you're gonna have
super consciousness dude you're [ __ ]
up
you're rolling balls man how are you
feeling super she says all this in a
room full of cameras i'm more nervous
than her to tell like a 911 joke to a
room of people who paid to see me and
she walks into that room and no one
knows what she's gonna say and she's
like i'm about to i'm about to just go
in on my pineal gland for a minute and
she doesn't even bat a eye just it must
be cool
it must be dope like living in that
world where you're just like i just go
out and say whatever like yeah but she
does they do get [ __ ] for her right like
i don't think she ever our article is
like what are they [ __ ] doing again
like what are they doing now her mgk
will jada i don't think they leave rooms
and go like i shouldn't have said that
yeah okay i don't i don't think they
have that thought right you know
i don't think they ever care yeah
there's just no sense of guilt or
you know you get that yeah that like
[ __ ] i could have said that better i do
also have to be a like a pick me real
quick not pick me but i like read about
a lot of this like these eastern
concepts like in high school it's just
so weird how like one year later because
i just left high school now everyone's
into it and literally like i was there
for no it's just my highlight was like
reading about this stuff it was very
like i would only tell my friends that i
was reading this stuff and i i felt very
crazy
even repeating these things i just think
it's so wild that celebrities like take
one transcendental like meditation class
and they're just on social media like i
literally found how to be god yeah yeah
it's like this is no like oh i'm gonna
go straight to twitter and like dude i
literally
am god unlocked to jesus christ i feel
him in me and i know how to control the
universe i can tell the future check out
my variety interview about it so what is
trends transcendental transcendental
meditation well that tm is like it's
been around for a minute seinfeld does
tm you could argue like some of these i
think this [ __ ] started in the 70s like
when
when
the 60s 70s and everyone was like really
into acid that's when a lot of those
cults were made you know like every
documentary now that's about like a cult
it always has like footage from the 60s
and 70s
so in that period there were a lot of
people that either took eastern ideas
and then like started their own cults or
whatever and so one of those things was
transcendental meditation and some of
these cults like ended up it's like
celebrities found them and then like
attached themselves to them so tm has
been around for like a long ass time but
it is in some ways you could say it's
just a cult but it's crazy because
seinfeld is like really into tm like he
but what do you what's the difference
between meditating and
tm
so how do you meditate but transcend
normal meditation so i don't know what
the teaching of tm is but like i think a
lot of these things it is mostly the
same it's just the language they use is
different but a lot of it is like you
have a physical body and you need to
transcend your like the material
consciousness and like you know you
should be in a place where you can rise
above like temptation and wants and you
know you should be able to like and once
you're past that now you can start to
focus on like your astral consciousness
right all it is is just like one big
[ __ ] ruse to like get you to think
that you can become god literally mm-hmm
which is like why
and and i'm like paraphrasing but it's
not that you are god but it's like you
can elevate your consciousness to like
god level and then you're godlike
literally yeah god like yeah
and then god mode
but that's the funny part is like
those things
it's so funny that like narcissists get
involved in this [ __ ] like they're the
last people i know it should be reading
books that are like you are god it's
like yeah yeah
finally someone understands yeah yeah
dude this is for me no tm is sick it's
like it's for sure
let me know like i am not crazy and it's
this world dude you're just like all
caught up in the material of life dude
my
mislead people are like people are
imagining us with like goblets and we're
like game of thrones drinking each
other's blood it's just a few drops
but yes we do consume each other's blood
on occasion for ritual purposes
only
it is used for a reason and it is
controlled where it's like let's shed a
few drops of blood i need to drink it
he's much more haphazard and hectic and
chaotic where he's willing to just like
cut his chest open with broken glass and
be like take my soul
let me bleed on you
it doesn't not happen let me tell you
maybe not exactly we have cell phones
like you don't have to do pagan rituals
anymore like this is over
it's
2022.
where are your kids where are your
children well they're around are they
they're in the next room like on vr
bothering them yeah she does she mothers
god she mothers for sure do you think
she mothers i think she mothers her i
don't i don't know it feels like she's
always on tour with mgk
they're drinking each other's blood no i
think where are your children i think
she mothers i just think they live a
very eccentric lifestyle